people of the internet welcome to our
let's play of harry potter
and the chamber of secrets if we're
meeting for the first time i'm
retroarching tour
i'm just a dad who loves games and the
stories they tell after we wrapped up
with our let's play of harry potter and
the philosopher's stone i decided to
post a poll on youtube
asking you guys what you wanted to see
next no surprise you said harry potter
and the chamber of secrets by a
huge margin i should also point out
we'll be playing the nintendo
gamecube version just for pure nostalgia
reasons that's the original version that
i played back when i was a kid so that's
what we're going to play on now we may
eventually do a pc play through as well
with harry potter and the chamber of
secrets because i know that one's a
little bit different
similar to the first game although i
know the first game was drastically
different i don't know how different the
second game is
but the video you're about to watch
today is part one of harry potter and
the chamber of secrets for the nintendo
gamecube all right here we go guys harry
potter and the chamber of secrets go
ahead and press start
if harry potter oh my goodness bring
back the memories
he will be in mortal danger
is that dobby i think that's i think
that's a dobby quote guys
[Music]
oh there's ron obviously a big
difference in the art style from the pc
version
that we most recently played
[Music]
wait what wait what is this
[Music]
what it's like they're going
to the borough it seems at first just
like the book starts
and then all of a sudden they they're i
mean i guess this is hogwarts they're
falling into some bit of lava hermione's
here now
[Applause]
i don't remember that scene we'll just
go with it
[Applause]
all right so we got a quidditch scene
now malfoy on the slytherin team here
number two
[Music]
whoa dueling club
i think we know what that is i think we
might know what that shadow is
all right here we go new game guys
all right let's do this man so if
i remember correctly it starts off at
the borough and you have to do something
with gnomes
something with gnomes at the borough do
you know me in the garden maybe
thinks what they call it
oh there it is look at the burrow guys
okay so like that cutscene is so bizarre
i felt like it was leading into this
moment and then it just goes
off the rails there so welcome to the
borough harry
all right
in the last video
did you care never as long as i believe
mum
now get outside let's start doing
gnoming i've had it up to here with all
of you
except you there it is there it is cross
with you
don't blame you harry no no
you ready to do a bit of denying then
harry well i'm not sure on i've been
with you
so much this summer i'm a little rusty
okay here we go whoa okay
camera no no
oh camera why would it be reversed by
default
what okay there we go much better
yeah i'm still kind of new to the whole
let's play thing i've done a lot of
twitch streams but interacting live on
twitch
i think it's very different from filming
a video
just for youtube and so i'm trying to
balance out what's the right amount of
talking so if you guys have any feedback
on that let me know
because on twitch you know you're
encouraged to be talking and interacting
constantly
but in the last video for harry and the
harry
potter
stone job with flippendo one of you was
commenting that i was talking
like over some of the in-game
explanations
and then after i was talking over it i
would say wait what did they say
and i would completely miss it so i'm
gonna try not to talk
quite as much in this one but still want
to interact with you guys so here we go
we got bertie bott's beans are found in
all kinds of places oh yeah we got to
bring back the birdie bop beans
gotta bring back the birdy ball beans
they can be used to trade with fred and
george when you reach hogwarts okay
excellent all right so i mean
fred and george i don't know why they're
just leaving them in their trash can
here but
okay underpants so you're capped out in
this
bottom left it was showing us at 3 out
of 50.
try hitting the glass jar with lupendo
guys just relax i want to i want to
explore a little bit first i want to see
what you guys got going on in the world
got the machine from gamble and james
so we could test the power of our spells
okay don't worry about getting the
shield to the top potter
once you learn some second year magic
you'll be able to ring the bell
well what about now am i strong enough
now
nope not strong enough okay i try to
make sure they're not hiding any other
birdie bop beat let's go harry hit the
glass jar
we need to get on with the d there you
go i hit the glass jar relax fred and
jor
that was truly smashing harry
when
when i'm ready okay now you're giving me
time to explore all right
this icon in the corner of the screen is
your remember all you can access this at
any time by pressing z
when it appears it means you have a new
task you can check it now
okay let's check it all right so i don't
know how similar the pc version is but i
know
uh wario in the comments was letting me
know in the last video he was saying hey
make sure you pay close attention to the
menu for chamber of secrets because
there's some very important stuff on
there so
i don't know if that applies to the
gamecube version as well but i'm still
going to take that advice
and i'm going to pay very close
attention here so
right away we already noticed that the
birdie bot beans are capped out in this
game it seems like you can't go above
50. so i will definitely want to spin
those
as i get them sickles collect these from
barrels to buy
items from the shops in diagon alley so
we've got a new currency in this game
up here we've got our uh looks like
spells are going to go here on this row
maybe
we'll pindo of course you got to start
with flopindo it wouldn't be right if
you didn't start with it
and it looks like i can cycle to
different
okay yeah we've got what three or four
pages here so there's the to do
smash some objects got that taken care
of meet ron fred and george in the bar
and then here oh our folio magi with the
wizard cards
you have not collected any cards yet of
course not let's see we've got nine
pages how many
total wizard cards are we're looking at
this time
101 wizard cards
101 cards very cool very cool oh and i
think there was one more page that i
that i missed out on let's see it was
oh the map there we go so we got a map
in this
this version that's really nice the
burrow pretty small area so
i don't know that we'll need it here but
so i'm going to run around just for a
little bit
make sure we don't have any other birdie
bop beams in the area
or wizard cards man those wizard cards
were so well hidden
in the first game i might have to go
back
[Music]
you said you said i could explore for a
little bit guys
relax there are gnomes
everywhere oh look they're up in the
rafters
yeah we see harry target the little
pests
so i'm playing with the controller
obviously for the gamecube version
and the first game i was using mouse
nailed them um oh how did that
hit him come on nice shot
wait i need to get my feet good harry
you've got the little pests
they're heading for the garden we'll
meet you out in the barnyard okay
they're gonna give me a second all right
oh and there was a chest there in the
background you guys see that
all right let's make sure we get the
chest right here
wizard card already let's go
let's go and you know we got to take a
look number three
el free de clag see they just in this
one they immediately take you
inside to check out the wizard card love
that love that little uh
quality of life feature so we've got
alfreda clack 1612
1680 chieftainess of warlocks council
number three here in our book very nice
very nice
there are 101 wizard cards to be
collected and traded increase your
stamina bar
with every 10 you collect all right so
that's another uh
new wrinkle in this game and right away
i mean
i i don't know the exact year difference
i would have to check on that there's a
barnyard
okay hogwarts legacy here's some advice
please don't rush us
like this game is to every time i try to
explore a little bit
i need to go here i need to go there
two wizard cards in the first room let's
go
see who this one is number one merlin
there's number one
most famous wizard of all time sometime
known as the prince of enchanters part
of the court of king arthur very nice
so wait the fact that we've got one and
three so far
does that mean they actually go in order
in this game like do i need to search
really close in this uh or really
carefully rather in this
barn to make sure that number two is not
in here
i'll say right off the bat though i mean
you can tell this one is just a massive
improvement
in in graphics from the first one
and again i don't know how many how many
years separated those first two games
look can we make it fall off what a nice
touch though
remember we know that uh you're going to
the barnyard mr weasley loves the rubber
ducks
tell me harry what exactly is the
function of a rubber duck
and here he is he has him in his yard
all right can i not
can i not blast those little
those hay bales or something bags of
feed i don't know
i want to try and blast them because
i can't aim up there there's no gnomes
to target
see if there's any more beans in there
all right well i don't see any other
chests in this room
hurry we're out here you know what i'm
just gonna ignore them i'm just gonna
ignore them we want to explore
weasleys come on
okay nothing in there nothing in there
all right we open that chest and all
right we're good let's go
harry we'd like you to meet our washing
machine huh
dad tried charming what now it's
anything but charming
this is a good opportunity to practice
some dueling julie
and watch out when the washing machine
opens its door and keep moving around
today
when the door is serious guys i can't be
laughing i'm gonna have a oh what is
this like a little mini boss
oh it's got a health bar and everything
oh my goodness it just charged me and
took two of my bees
watch out
he's gonna charge again oh
oh okay i need to wait for when he opens
they said
yeah there we go we got that dodge down
there we go
harry doesn't dodge far enough like i'm
pressing it but
you can only damage it when the doors
open
oh my goodness lock on harry lock on
there we go one more hit maybe really
scared harry it won't fight there we go
all right we got him
i'd love to see that in aunt petunia's
kitchen
you look like you need a chocolate frog
chocolate fruit there you go
all right you have to knock the fog out
before you can catch it
okay let's go throw some gnomes we'll
meet you in the garden when you're ready
harry
you have to knock the frog out before
you can catch it that's another new
element in this one so the frogs
you don't just walk over them yeah see
it doesn't doesn't do anything i have to
boom get a move on potter guys
relax freaking relax
please all right so
dino the garden all right just just let
me check my to-do list
okay guys i want to make sure there's
not a wizard card out here that i'm
missing i've already got number one and
number three
number two could be out here somewhere
get inside there
no all right the washing machine is just
it's relaxed now
we took care of it nothing a little
pindo can't fix you know
oh i hear the gnomes i remember just
getting so frustrated
you need to get a movement mom will go
mad if she finds any gnomes left in the
garden
look there's one over there what you
have to do
is flipendo them until they're dazed and
confused then you grab hold of them
and spin them around
and you shut them up oh yes so yeah what
frustrated me so much
there's like no momentum
are you kidding me oh we're gonna we're
gonna get all the targets
and we're gonna throw it farther than
fred but yeah it's like
the momentum on it is really weird you
have to release
it all right let's try this i'm gonna go
for a target first
oh that's that's way farther than fred
yeah 266 right
derwent shrimp and we get a wizard card
okay so i think that confirms that they
don't go
in order unless i just missed like four
wizard cards which is possible
it is possible derwent shimpling 1912 to
present
ate an entire venomous tentacula for a
bet and survive
though is still purple so there you go
guys magic cannot solve
our problems so we got a wizard card
just for throwing it farther than fred i
wonder if we also get one
if we hit both targets so we're gonna go
for next
all right let's go for well they're
pretty close so
get one oh very close
i started wondering if there's actually
a dog barking outside my window or if
it's the game
i think it's a game we've got dogs and
we've got
we've got ducks all kinds of ducks
all man we should be able to hit one of
these easy but i want to go for both
definitely want to go for both because
they're i think
there could be a wizard card tied to it
yeah see i'm releasing
all right so we need to release just a
little bit sooner
to try and hit i can't believe the first
one that we tried over here we threw
right between them
[Music]
all right now we need to go for the
scarecrow
where's that last one i thought he was
over here
oh i hear him i hear him
stereo sound for the wind all right so
the scarecrow's not quite as
far out there
now we hit the hay bale again target
[Music]
no it's going to be over isn't it
no i want to try some scare boys time
for bed
big day tomorrow diagon alley then
platform night
for someone who's never denomed before
i think you deserve a chocolate frog two
chocolate frogs
back to back when you've completed all
your tasks for one day you'll be given
the option to end day in your remembral
at this point you can continue to
explore the world oh
nice or you can decide to end day and
the next day's adventure can then
begin all right so can i oh yes i can
still keep de-gnoming
we gotta go for that scarecrow
okay gotta go for the scarecrow
there oh not even close dude not even
close
that was a wicked rush
you guys still have a lot of gnomes so
what's gonna happen is i'm gonna finally
get it
and it's not gonna be tied to anything
oh my goodness see there's like no
momentum it goes
directly where you release it is where
it goes which i guess should make it
easier but i'm so used to games like
actually taking momentum and things like
that into account now
right on time here we go dude there we
go
finally got the scarecrow
now it says when you've completed all
your tasks for one day you'll be given
the option okay so you're telling me
basically that
i've done everything imaginable and i
did not get a wizard card for it
so be it i'm a completionist
[Music]
all right so we're gonna go here and now
we need to look for
where we end day okay so we're gonna go
to to-do list here yeah and now we just
press a
weasley woke them all early the
following wednesday she took a flower
pot off the kitchen mantelpiece
and everyone grabbed a handful of flu
powder
let's go powder before and when he
scattered the powder into the fireplace
he immediately swallowed a lot of hot
ash
dude the ducks did not stop it felt as
though he was being sucked down goodness
harry tried to keep his eyes open but
the whirling made him feel sick
he normally closed his eyes
he fell all right knocked her an alley
oh here we go guys
dude i i honestly love the art style of
this game
i think it's i think it works so well
for harry potter
oh he's walking slow look at that
creeping around dude
i need to worry about like waking
somebody oh what is this
this is safe oh goodness
what's going on this is a save game
scroll
okay good yeah we needed that we haven't
saved yet and i don't know that there's
an auto save
walk up to the scroll and press a to
confirm your save saving at a save game
scroll
at any time we'll override any previous
progress okay that's fine
okay i'm actually a little bit curious
to get close to that skull again
oh what is it not gonna do it now
oh that's just there he goes he waits
for you to turn around
it's like that's just creepy
look at all these oh wait search what
was that
look at that it popped up there see it
birdie
they just got a birdie about being
randomly sitting in here
i just noticed it pop up in the in the
top right
beside the a button i was like what is
that exactly oh that's not creepy at all
anything else in here that we can find
yeah search that harry oh
what is this pumpkin pastry
i think it's pumpkin pasty right
pumpkin pastry okay oh does that i
wonder if that gives you health as well
because yeah it didn't go in my
inventory anywhere
so maybe it's like a wizard or a
chocolate frog
otherwise not really sure what the point
is but
oh my goodness
the freaking hand man
the hand of glory is that what it's
called
[Music]
i kind of want to get my bean back oh
it's gone oh and i lost that bean
dude
that seriously made me jump i forgot
about that i knew there was something in
here that was
like that would attack you
oh my gosh i'm not even close that time
come on no i want my beads i've lost my
beans
okay i won't go for the final bean
i could just reload to save no i'm not
going to do that i'm not going to do
that
i will grab this bean right here though
okay anything else here all right i
think i go in here
oh man here we go
it's lucius and draco malfoy mr mouthful
nothing draco
wow that's mr book is actually really
big mr malfoy
what a pleasure to see you again the
ministry of magic is conducting more
raids and i have a few more
wow items like this at home that might
embarrass me
i know people don't love chamber of
secrets to books i mean
i love all of them
i'll expect you tomorrow's your manner
to pick them up
good day good day
and there it is guys a horcrux
right there our first exposure to a
horcrux
of voldemort but yeah that's what i was
gonna say i know people don't
love chamber of secrets the book at
least from all the lists that i see you
know people do tier lists and stuff
online
it doesn't seem that that one is usually
rated very high
but i love the fact that
there's that much foreshadowing of okay
is this going to attack me too
you know what i think that i can get
close to the hand
if i kind of walk like this
wait did he just what
what just wait that's not the diary
[Music]
that's right because he doesn't give the
diary he doesn't leave the diary here
oh wow okay you've gained a new spell
lumos
you can assign it to b y or x simply by
pressing the button now
spells or equipment can also be assigned
in the inventory screen of your remember
all yes okay so assigning different
spells i'll put it on y
there all right okay so it
gives you a little description here of
what it does light re
lights dark areas and reveals hidden
panels okay so
this is a little bit different from how
it behaved in the philosopher's stone
game and this is much closer to
what it actually does they still kind of
add a little bit of a twist on it but to
illuminate the end of a wand the caster
must call out the incantation
lumos the end of the wand will then
illuminate and cast light in the
immediate vicinity of the caster
lumos can also be used to illuminate
unseen entrances
and it is a little known fact that
certain shops in the gloomier parts of
diagon alley
may be further explored with lumos
a further use of the spell is that it
can be effective against an
anthropomorphic spirits in dark forested
areas but be warned
lumos fades after a period of time and
must be recast
okay oh cool i like that little
description there
a little overview yeah so i think as
long as i don't run around
that's the whole reason that they allow
you to kind of creep around right here
obviously come on retro you're better
than this
there we go all right we got lumos here
i'm gonna go ahead and save again
just because i wouldn't have to play
through all that again
anything over here definitely definitely
something hidden behind there but
all right so it's said that we can use
lumos to illuminate i know i know where
we're supposed
to go i remember that but i just want to
make sure there's not anything
hidden oh wow it doesn't last very long
at all
so there's no meter or anything i don't
have to worry about running out of
spell energy or anything like that oh
wait i saw another
search pop up there it is
yeah one more beam might as well
might as well since the hand took like
what two or three of them from us
okay
all right here we go we gotta get out of
here guys
we've got to get out of organ and berks
oh wait there we go
okay oh chest
search
yeah i just saw it right there so it
gives you health okay so it's just like
a chocolate frog just another health
[Music]
item
all right gotta find our way to the
weasleys
lock on oh goodness
dude it's like really close quarters
here
yeah get rid of all your all your vases
that you could hide behind
i open this
oh you can hop up there
yeah let's trap you in the cage
oh i couldn't see i thought it was like
a cutscene
i thought it was a cutscene playing
there
all right pick him up pick him up
is there a cage yeah here's an open one
right here
get in there dude
they're so tiny they're not strong
enough to like push up on there there's
not even a latch or anything holding it
all right so yeah now we can use these
i'm gonna use lumos though
make sure there's not
a hidden item
it really does not last long at all okay
there's clearly where i'm supposed to go
but
oh can i not jump back up there i wanted
to explore that area a little bit more
all right fine
[Music]
anything over here oh i i know there's a
birdie bot bean
whoa another skull
what is this that's scabbers
pal treats can be fed to owls to
encourage them to do
favors for you i completely forgot about
that mechanic
completely forgot about that
[Music]
no birdie bop being over here are you
for real
man those things are loud
oh here we go call ahead head wing
i'll give you a treat help me out of
here
i mean lucky that there's this al perch
right here ilops premium owl treats the
best thing
for a happy healthy owl here you go is
that what we found
all right hedwig how you gonna help me
out of this one
there she goes oh wait what okay
nice job hedwig i don't know where he
found the ladder
but i am thankful and appreciative all
right let's get out of here
let's get out of here guys
oh not out of here yet though
goodness that scared me i'm glad it did
though because
look at this yes what's your card so
cards make me excited guys
you all know i love seeing them more
than anything else number 98
dymphnafirmage dymfnaffirmage1612 1698
yet again
not alive in the hogwarts legacy time
range famously
abducted by pixies while on vacation in
cornwall and lived in mortal dread of
them thereafter
jeez file to persuade the ministry
we filed filed to persuade the ministry
of magic to have all pixies humanely
destroyed just you know
kill all of them please do it humanely
thank you
oh wow okay so clearly they ain't going
they do not go in order because then we
jumped all the way to 98 now
all right the camera is really weird
sometimes it
like it won't let me have full control
over it right now
okay kind of afraid the floor is going
to go out again
oh there we go look at that dude
look at that lumo's showing me the way
all right crawl into
all right
again
and this game really does not want you
exploring much like it kind of
it was kind of forcing me like here's
the way you want to go
all right fine fine i'll go this way
oh are we almost out i think we're
almost out guys
to keep a low profile you can sneak by
pressing harry up against
walls you can also cast a spell whilst
peeking around corners
all right how do i do how do i
yes birdie bop beans in the trash can
birdie bop beans
beans
hogwarts crest say what
dude how do i get over there
oh and there's a there's a chest in
there too
do i just need to like hit that switch
not let me aim
maybe there's something up here it's
casting this make sure there's not like
a
a switch or something
all right so i think is right here where
we're supposed to
wall sneak okay
it's contextual but man you have to be
like right up against the wall
for it to show up
man i really want what's back there
and i'm afraid if i go too far it's not
going to let me grab
oh here we go
open the door's locked no no no no no
there we go okay good i was like please
i don't want to leave here yet
i want to see what's back here looks
like it's actually required
whatever is back here maybe a key for
that door or something
all right
oh not a key okay because that the
button unlocks that
all right so what's in here wizard card
yes
wizard god wizard god
[Music]
number five yes
we've got our first potential
candidate i mean almost certainly
no it's it's hogwarts like he's late
1800s right
darn it i don't think 1839 it's not late
by any definition
man okay so we could meet like his if he
had any children
we could meet them so gulliver pokebee
1750-1839
expert on magical birds first to
identify
meaning of augury song that's cool
number five right there all right so so
far we've gotten a lot of them on this
first page here
any beans any beans all right fine
yeah they really did add a lot of new
mechanics
for this this game compared to the first
again quite a bit of time past though as
well
games advanced a lot you know all right
are we
are we fully out of nocturn alley yet or
do we have to kind of make our way
through it here
let's see it could be a cut scene or
could actually have us sneaking a little
bit more
i completely forgot it's it's been so
long since i played it
okay so i think we're out yes let's save
right here
all right guys i think that's a great
place to stop thank you all so much for
watching if you haven't seen my let's
play of harry potter the philosopher's
stone i'll put a link to that up on the
left side of the screen right now
eventually we'll have the next chamber
of secrets links on the top right
if you enjoy this be sure to give it a
thumbs up thank you so much for watching
and i'll talk to you again soon